aaron how are you and tom going to teach
those young bucks a lesson on the golf
course in vegas
well look tom and i have gotten to be on
the course many times uh you know in
tournaments and just out with some
friends but
to be able to go out
with a couple fans is going to be really
nice
and i look forward to the opportunity to
showing these uh these young guys a
little some on the course last year you
know tommy was on my the other team
had to give him a beat down this year
will be nice to win it with him tom
aaron i know uh my good friend barkley
you know when he's on the golf course he
likes to do wages are you guys gonna
have a little friendly wager
always you gotta stay focused i know
charles had quite a few over the years
but um
whatever those young guys want to bet i
know i'm probably the the lowest paid
guy out there on the golf course this
time around between those three
uh heavy hitters but whatever they want
i got action on those guys and although
i would say golf's not my number one
squirt
yeah he's got a way of bringing out the
best of me so i i think we're ready to
take on these young bucks well tom
number one if you're worried about being
the lowest paid guy why don't you just
quit retire again and go to tv i hear
some got some change coming your way
all in due time i think you guys are
doing just fine yourself speaking of
that i love your guy's show
you know i said i told shaq when i had
dinner with them a few weeks ago how
great the show is the best camaraderie i
think everybody in television tries to
emulate what you guys do so keep it up
it's like a it's like a very
dysfunctional
thanksgiving family dinner you guys are
doing really well it sure is
functional right we had uh josh allen on
the podcast and he said their advantage
is going to be off the tee they're going
to be driving it way past you you you
old guys
uh do you think the short game is going
to be really important you think you can
keep up with those guys off the tee
look charles i've done my scouting
report and i heard that josh was
terrible in pebble
and
pat has played the last couple years in
tahoe and hasn't broken 80 yet so
i think he was closer to being a group
with you no offense charles and maybe
with me at tahoe so i feel really good
about our chances the thing that isn't
taken into account is that tom is the
ultimate competitor and i know he's been
training really really hard with his
swing coach he might not have as many
swing coaches as tony romo but i know
he's getting after it and he'll be ready
to play
come june 1st you know tom aaron i
always wondered like when you go from a
sport and now
you're actually in front of a crowd in a
sport that you take for leisure
do you have any of the same nerves that
you have when you actually playing
football like any of those nerves come
up
oh yeah
the first time so the first of all i
think
what i look really love about the match
is so much is for charity and i think
we've raised over 33 million dollars for
charity uh so i think really being a
part of this since the original i think
the match two
uh with tiger and with phil is really
something special so i remember getting
over the tee box in that match it was
pouring rings that medalist that you
know the fairways are about this wide
and uh i looked down at the ball and i
couldn't feel my arms i'm like how am i
going to hit the ball i can't feel my
fricking arms
and uh sure enough i've somehow found a
way on the back to put some things
together but it's definitely
a different challenge i've never felt
that on the football field but on the
golf course i definitely feel that
aaron are you playing more of practicing
more leading into the match
[Applause]
i don't practice
i don't practice i might play a little
bit but but i'm going to go in and trust
my instincts and i got a great partner
who like i said have been training
really really hard for this uh out there
swinging on the range with this helmet
on maybe shoulder pads so he can kind of
get both in at the same time
so i feel i feel really good about her
chances
i don't know if you guys are aware uh
because it came on late at night the
other night but we did have the
highlights of the annual black masters
uh so named by charles and finally for
the first time he was able to to claim
the black jacket
uh anything you'd like to say to charles
who is still basking in the glory of his
championship
i've seen him swing
tell him go ahead
i've seen the swing on the range charles
and
and i've been impressed because i've
been at tahoe for 17 years and seen a
lot of iterations everything from
two-handed to one hand at the right hand
the left hand
uh to the hits and no hits so i'm i'm
happy for you big fella and i'm proud of
you i don't see shaq out there though
because i had one match with a 45 foot
putt to win to beat charles and i beat
him i retired after that you remember
that man i remember that bubba watson
with you too doesn't matter and you know
what uh charles though i don't remember
anything they said just now
kenny's been mesmerized
tom brady aaron rodgers thank you very
much we look forward to being out there
june 1st me and chuckster uh to call the
match and we uh we appreciate you taking
some time thanks y'all
thank you guys